position du matin
ouais
Alysse
toi
Claudia Murr ar-15s je fais sept auberges
j'en fais cinq
puis
pour les bas de Rome au troisième étage Wanda
tout comme nous nous sommes entraînés qu'en est-il de l'
invité,
qu'en est-il de notre autre recrue tu es
impatient d'y aller
et je  mettez un peu de café dedans mais
vous devriez être bon
je sais quel fuseau horaire était ce hein essayez
Captain America mr.  Wang
c'est un honneur je te serre la main trop
longtemps wow c'est génial
Captain America je te connais aussi tu es
génial jeez oh regarde je veux dire je sais que
tu connais beaucoup de super personnes alors merci
d'avoir pensé à moi hey mec  quoi de neuf
tic-tac ah bon de vous voir regardez ce qui
s'est passé la dernière fois c'était une super
audition mais ça n'arrivera
plus jamais ils vous disent ce que nous avons
contre
quelque chose à propos de certains assassins psychopathes
nous sommes en dehors de la loi  sur celui-ci donc si
tu viens avec nous tu es un homme recherché
ouais eh bien quoi d'autre est nouveau
Tonie quelqu'un meurt sous ta montre tu
n'abandonnes pas qui a dit que nous abandonnons
nous proposons de ne pas assumer la responsabilité de
nos actions
ce document  ne fait que déplacer le blâme
désolé Steve que c'est dangereusement
arrogant c'est des Nations Unies dont
nous parlons ce n'est pas le
Conseil de sécurité mondial ce n'est pas un bouclier ce n'est
pas Hydra mais c'est dirigé par des gens avec des
agendas et des changements d'agenda c'est bien
c'est pourquoi je suis  ici quand j'ai réalisé ce que
mes armes étaient capables  e ou entre de mauvaises
mains je l'ai arrêté arrêtez la fabrication seulement
vous avez choisi de le faire si nous signons
ceci, nous abandonnons notre droit de choisir et
si ce panneau nous envoie quelque part, nous
ne pensons pas que nous devrions aller et si
quelque part nous devons  partez et ils ne
nous laissent pas nous ne sommes peut-être pas parfaits mais les
mains les plus sûres sont toujours les nôtres si nous
ne le faisons pas maintenant, cela nous sera fait
plus tard